alright I'll tackle in the last video we
did the first part of Part A now to the
second part of Part A so the second part
of Part A they say calculate the number
of moles of ethene that would be
produced if the dehydration reaction
went to completion well this is the
dehydration reaction right over here and
they're telling us they're telling us
that we start with zero point two zero
zero grams of ethanol so if we start
with zero point two zero zero grams of
ethanol and if we figure out how many
moles of ethanol that is well for every
mole of ethanol if we have the reaction
go to if the dehydration reaction goes
to completion for every mole of ethanol
that we start with we're going to have a
mole of ethene and a mole of water so if
we can just figure out how many moles of
ethanol this is then we'll say okay if
this were to completely react we would
have that many moles of ethene so let's
figure this out so if we say so we have
ethanol so for ethanol we are starting
with zero point two zero zero grams and
we want to convert this to moles so we
want to multiply this times we want
grams in the denominator to cancel out
with this grams and moles in the
numerator so one mole of ethanol is as a
mass of how many grams well they tell us
that earlier on the problem they say
ethanol molar mass forty six point one
grams per mole so ethanol molar mass of
forty six point one grams per mole or
another way to thinking about it one
mole would have a mass of forty six
point one grams and so if we do this we
are going to get zero point two zero
zero over forty six point one and then
grams cancel with
grams and that's going to be how many
moles we have and this is going to be
equal to we have three significant
digits that we're going to be dealing
with three significant digits divided by
three significant digits so this is
going to be all right so let me clear
this
so 0.2 I could write zero zero but it's
going to for the calculators purposes
it's the same thing divided by forty six
point one is equal to zero point zero
zero four three I want three significant
figures here so for three I'm going to
round up for three four point zero zero
four three four so zero point zero zero
four three four moles so what we've seen
so far if the ethanol were we the
reaction if we have this many moles of
ethanol well if we and if they
completely react well that we should end
up with that many moles of ethene and so
in if we have if we could say
dehydration let me write it this way if
dehydration dehydration reaction goes to
completion goes to completion every
every mole of ethanol ethanol would be
converted converted to a mole of ethene
and a mole of water I shouldn't write
the shorthand there a mole if I'm
writing it out mole of and a mole of
water so so zero point zero zero four
three four mole of ethanol would
yield that same number of moles zero
point zero point zero zero four three
four moles of ethene so if the reaction
went to completion that's how many moles
you would produce what we actually
measure is a smaller number than that so
the reaction and go fully to completion
so now let's tackle Part B let's tackle
Part B and they ask us calculate the
percent yield of ethene in the
experiment well that's the percent yield
is if is going to be how much we got
divided by how much we would ideally
have gotten if the reaction went fully
to completion so yield yield is going to
be equal to how much we actually got
which we figured out in part one so zero
point zero zero two six four moles over
what we actually got or so what we
actually got over what we would have
ideally gotten if the reaction went to
completion so divided by zero point zero
zero four three four moles and this is
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to so zero zero two six four
divided by zero zero four three four is
equal to and let's you have three
significant digits here so sixty I could
say point six zero eight or I could say
sixty point eight percent yield so I
could write this as actually it's going
to I'm rounding so I could say is 60.8%
yield and there you go